[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's going on youtube it's cameron
it's great to be back
um
it's been a hot minute since i've been
here a couple weeks i think um but it's
great to be back i got a new camera let
me know if you guys can see me okay if
you can hear me okay
um it's a new
artificial intelligence camera so it's
kind of weird it's funny if i move
around it
kind of follows where i go
so i have my own little
personal cameraman
um
so it's great to be here today uh today
is january 4th tuesday
happy new year everybody hope you're
enjoying the new year hope you had um
some fun for the new year i had a great
time
got to hang out with some family and
friends
uh today i am
talking
um
well actually we're talking
ask me anything general questions
i'm going to answer any question you may
have for me
do my best to answer it for you
so this is your chance to ask me
anything you want to ask me
related to motion design
but before we do that tell you a little
bit about myself for those of you who
don't know me um my name is cameron
i've been a motion designer for over 20
years
working in after effects in cinema 4d
i taught myself motion design i taught
myself animation and then i taught
myself design
i built demo reels out of spec work i
created for myself that's how i landed
my very first motion design job that
actually paid me
after that i was a remote freelancer for
13 years
before remote freelancing was even a
thing
i've owned and operated two small
boutique post houses
and i've had the opportunity to build
projects for studios like
prolog films digital kitchen agencies
like publicis and ogilvy and mather and
i've got to work with clients like 343
industries amazon american express
disney
mtv rca sony and many
many more
uh it's great to see you guys here today
i see some questions coming in that's
awesome
um also before i get to these questions
i also want to tell you that i've got a
free workshop i've got a free workshop
it's over
at
motionscience.tv workshop
you can see it on the screen right there
i'm going to show you seven secrets to
cinematic motion design
these are seven tips tricks and concepts
behind pro level motion design that i'm
going to teach you
it's a quick 30 minute workshop
it doesn't take all day it's to the
point plus i give you access to a
special offer at the end
you're not going to find anywhere else
it's an awesome awesome offer
and uh
hope to see you there at my free
workshop
okay so we got some awesome people here
today people i recognize
uh alexandra what's going on moe what's
going on
brandon hey hey
jw hello
jason l hey everyone
uh matt maltese
sad boy
what is going on people
um okay so if you have a question you
know don't don't be shy
no question is stupid
uh no question is not important
i love to answer as many questions as i
can
and i'll answer as many as i can while
i'm on here so
don't be shy
feel free to ask your question i'm happy
to answer it for you
okay
sad boy doesn't have a question but
wants to see something new
yeah what does that mean sad boy
what do you want to see that's something
new
uh matt maltese
what's a good way to generate concepts
for ideas for personal design or
animation projects
what's a good way to generate concepts
for ideas or ideas for personal projects
or just animation design or animation
projects that's great question matt
um
so a good way to generate concepts or
ideas is to keep
mood boards okay and i've talked a lot
about this in some other videos
but keeping mood boards
uh in applications like pinterest
and instagram in your photo app within
your phone
uh on your computer
any place that you can create a mood
board that is an opportunity for you to
save
design
that inspires you and it doesn't have to
be motion design it could be
a screenshot of a magazine it could be a
photo of a piece of architecture
it could be a movie it could be a music
track
it doesn't matter it's
anything that inspires you
you want to
hang on to that piece
so you can always come back to it and
reference it right so
um
[Music]
i have a lot of boards on pinterest so
if you go to pinterest.com
motion science i believe you're going to
see i have a whole lot of boards there
for ideas i've got boards on typography
i've got boards on
uh colors on textures on 3d on form on
shape online
uh title design
movie intros uh cd covers right album
covers i guess no one uses cds really
much anymore uh album i mean anything
architecture anything that inspires me i
keep in a mood board
i've got um photo albums here on my
phone
that i
organize into folders
that i reference all the time i was
actually referencing one last night i
was i'm
been
jones into design some new stuff and you
know a lot of my time gets spent
building courses or
free material for youtube
for you guys so a lot of times i'm
focused more on that
and i don't get to spend as much time
these days creating so it's like last
night i was pulling up
folder structures within my phone
of screenshots i've taken and some of
them are screenshots some of them are
screen recordings
and i'm looking at pieces that i've
captured over time
to get inspiration i immediately got
some inspiration for a piece i want to
try to create for myself now you know
i'm not taking
you're taking pieces of things that
inspire you and you're kind of like
you're bringing those together to create
your own thing so
um
nothing created today is is new nothing
everything has been done over and over
and over again
but it's all about
that artist's take on what that is that
they're creating so
um
i'm always looking for inspiration
saving that inspiration and then pulling
from that inspiration to create new
things and it typically it just takes me
looking at a couple pieces to be like
boom that's something i want to try
myself put my own spin on it
so for example
this piece last night was like a
um it was like a five second animated
screen recording i took off of instagram
and i can't remember who the artist was
um but it was like kind of retro like
and it was
very computer based and you'll probably
see this on my instagram feed coming up
in the next week or so
because i'll try and do some myself but
it was very inspiring from the look of
it
and it was something that was shape
layer based
and uh really cool audio so what did i
do i immediately was inspired by that
piece
i jumped off there i went to my favorite
audio search sites which are epidemic
sound and audio jungle
and i immediately searched for like a
computer sound i was looking for and i
went through probably a hundred
different tracks took me probably 10 15
minutes because i just go through them
real fast
and i found five audio pieces that were
inspiring to me
um
and i saved those five pieces i
downloaded the previews of them
some of them have watermarks some don't
doesn't matter
so now those are sitting in a folder
and i've set aside a thursday of this
week to design and i'm going to design
that piece so i've got my visual
reference
that i saw
i watched it a few times over and over
again i don't need to pull that back
back into my reference again i know it
in my head i'm like okay i know i was
inspired by
it was shape player base it was retro
based it was computer-based
i've seen it
i don't need to go back and reference it
to where i'm copying something
i was inspired by it i've got my audio
track because audio is very inspiring to
me
and now i'm going to build it
design it
in after effects on thursday so that's a
good way to generate concepts or ideas
um again if it's something
you said for personal design i mean
that's it's super easy to do just as
much inspiration reference as you have
the more you have the better
right
you don't
anytime you're inspired just take
a mental just very quickly just save
that somewhere
right and that's why like a lot of times
i'm on my phone i'm scrolling through
instagram
and i'm saving screenshots or screen
recordings if i'm on my computer
um
like in behance i'm in behan sometimes
i'm going to save i'm going to
appreciate that project i'm going to
save it to a board
if i'm
in my email pinterest sends me emails
once or twice a week like hey these are
some great things we think that you may
like some inspiration you may you may
like
uh so i'm going to save though i'm going
to take
five minutes i'm going to open up those
emails and look through those images
very quickly and scan through those
click some that i
immediately am drawn to
if they are very inspiring to me i will
save them to a board for future
reference so
those are some simple ways to generate
concepts for personal design or
animation and also you know it's it's
great to take multiple pieces
like maybe a piece of typography
inspired you maybe a texture inspired
you and maybe a music track inspired you
and just maybe take all three of those
and combine them and create something
completely new so don't be afraid to
to try something new also when you're
creating for personal
limit yourself
creatively limit yourself creatively
limit the amount of typefaces you're
using the amount of audio tracks you're
you're searching for
don't spend too much time on it because
we can get wrapped up and spending too
much time on something and going round
and round and round
with it and not getting anywhere
so
maybe for a personal project you allow
yourself a few hours
maybe you allow yourself a day
for my particular like because that was
one of my new year's goals is to start
is to create more i'm not going to
create daily i just don't have you know
some artists are doing dailies
i don't have the capacity to do that
um to me it's more important to uh
work as little as possible
spend time with my family and just enjoy
the the sun where i live
um
so
my goal for 2022 is to create weekly
right just one it can be a design still
design or
design an animation doesn't matter what
it is create it weekly so that means
like for me on thursday
i'll probably spend
two to three hours
playing around with this design concept
i have
uh if something comes out of it great
sometimes they'll flow really quickly
and easily
sometimes it doesn't so maybe i'll spend
a few hours on it and then i'll break
and then maybe at night before i go to
bed i get creative sometimes i'll spend
maybe another hour on it and see what
happens
maybe i'm done with it at that point
maybe it's really coming along and it's
really cool and maybe i'll spend another
hour to
you know friday or saturday on it but
it's nice to take a break from it as
well so
limit yourself creatively don't
spend days and days on something
um
unless it's some great piece but you
know like
when we're building personal pieces for
our demo reels for our websites
you know at most they need to be five to
ten seconds i mean five seconds is
pretty long so if you're creating a five
second piece that's animated
i mean that's a that's a big chunk of
your demo reel right there right you
don't need to create 15 20 30 seconds
long of a piece i mean that just puts so
much pressure on you
uh to create such a long piece so just
keep it very short
and succinct is that right yeah
paul what's up paul
oh sad boy sorry i missed you there
central asia
uzbekistan awesome
glad to have you here
paul can we get an in-depth tutorial on
understanding expressions
yeah go to after effects academy volume
2.
that's where i talk
i stay away from expressions as much as
possible you know i use the wiggle
expression
the wiggle expression is super super
powerful can be used for so many
different things
i'm going to say go to after effects
academy volume two that's where i get
into to deeper
levels of expressions as deep as i go
um
if you want a really deep understanding
of expressions
euchremedia.com those guys are awesome
i really they're good dudes and um
their courses on expressions are really
powerful
um
but they go way deeper than you know
what i
tend to go i i don't go nearly as deep
as they do
but after effects academy volume 2
is where i would say if you want to
learn what you need to learn and not get
super into coding
that's where you're going to find that
um
uh black smoke alexandro what's going on
man
for those of you that don't know i know
alexander because he's in multiple many
of my courses many of my courses uh will
there ever be an updated version of the
beyond the parallax effect i really love
it
yeah so um
there so there's not per se a course on
it so if you don't know i sold beyond
the parallax to ae juice
so they have that course now
uh jacob over there another great dude
great company um i feel like it was time
to retire it from motion science
um
i have you know multiple tutorials on
parallax effect
the parallax effect um
throughout
different parts of motion science so um
like if you look at the
motion design mastery system
over at motionscience.tv or you look at
stylecraft
these new offers
they have a course and they're called
rock and roll parallax
which
is a workshop that was originally part
of pro flows which is no longer around i
don't remember if you were in pro flows
or not
um but it's you know
it goes into parallax effect
in that sense um there's some other
workshops
you know individual lessons kind of
scattered throughout motion science that
do focus on the parallax effect but
there's no like new course per se on
that and i don't
know that there will be one
in the near future
well we do have a new course coming out
this year that's i'm pretty excited
about
uh
see here
um
subhash subash
sorry if i pronouncing your name wrong
uh hey cameron how difficult is it to
get work if someone is a self-taught
motionographer oh man great question it
is not challenging if you put in the
work okay
this is what i did
um i was self-taught i am self-taught
i put in the work
to learn after effects and motion
graphics back in the it wasn't called
motion designs called motion graphics
back in the day now this is in 1998 99
2000
long time ago
and
um
there were not courses that exist back
then so the great thing with you guys is
that you have all these courses to pick
from you have free content on youtube
which is great and it's why people like
myself post
on youtube to teach um but if you want
to get
better faster
you need to look into a course
uh to help you
get better as a motion designer very
quickly
of course i'm going to promote motion
sciences courses i think that we're the
best i know that we're the best
but there's a lot of other courses out
there from other providers that are good
too
so
get into these courses learn as much as
you can
you know as quickly as you can
and then
build spec work right so spec work is
work that you want to create that kind
of creatively fulfills you
and that spec work goes on your demo
reel and you build
an awesome awesome demo reel
and then you put that demo reel out
to various companies or agencies
or you know clients whoever it may be
and you try and land that work
now
um
i'm going to tell you i'll tease to you
guys i do have
i have a membership coming up that's
going to start in
february
i believe february or march
um we're going to open it up
and it's just for people like you um
subhash
it's all about
let's
you've done the courses you've done the
work
now what now what do you do right how do
you
you know how to create motion design
just
different whatever level you're at
doesn't matter if you're
you know very
beginner level or your immediate level
intermediate or you're very pro level
it's for all of you and it's to teach
you how
to get that paying work right if you
want to be a freelancer or if you want
just a high paying job
that's what this membership is going to
teach you um so i'm really excited about
it you guys are actually the first to be
hearing about it it hasn't officially
launched yet
um but
going back to it it's it's creating work
you want to create work that you want to
get more of so if you're really into
particle systems you're going to create
particles you know a reel of particle
work if you're into character animation
you're going to create a reel of
character animation if you're into
visual effects you're going to create a
real visual effects
you're going to create spec work five
second pieces three second pieces
whatever you're going to edit it
together into demo reel and this work is
going to be your absolute best work
and it's work that
you're going to put your heart and soul
into you're going to create a demo reel
and you're going to send that out that
reel out to people people will hire you
based upon the work they see in that
reel
so then you're getting paid
to do this work
that creatively fulfills you so it's
this endless cycle
of you you start by creating spec work
for yourself for your real put out to
the world people start paying you to
create more of that work that newer work
replaces maybe the little the less
strong work on your reel and your reel
gets better and better how you get
better work that pace is paying you and
it's just like it's a great cycle to be
in
it doesn't matter if you're self-taught
or not
um
any good post house
agency i've ever worked for they have
they do not care
they do not care what your credentials
are they care
what's on your reel
right and if you're be if you're good
easy to work with that's what they care
about
so it's not difficult
to get work as a self-taught
motionographer
it's just a matter of creating a real
that's strong and putting it out to the
right people
hey mo what's going on
uh mo says
when you have done titles in the past
did you work strictly in after effects
or did you also work combination the
output in premiere pro
so from my own personal experience i was
only in after effects and sometimes a 3d
program
we always had an editor
who was
doing the actual edit
most of my experience was with avid back
in the day um
they're working avid somewhere in final
cut pro
[Music]
premier pros just the same
um
but yeah it was mostly just an editor
sending you know there was a whole
process to it basically where an editor
would completely block something
he would block the piece out he or she
would block the title sequence out um
starting from like basically just still
images cut to a music track
attempt music track
and then i would see that start filling
in the scenes seen by scene by scene
whether it was me or me and a team
typically it was me and a team of other
designers we would go back to the you
know send the work back to the editor he
would plug it in
we'd watch it together we'd all take
notes we'd all take
critiques from the client
from other designers
and go back and keep refining it and
that would happen
multiple times over and over again
until the final sequence was done
um but you know these days it really
just depends if you're if you're
creating a title sequence for like an
independent film you may be the only
person working on it and that's an
opportunity for you to work yes with
after effects in premiere pro
um it's the same process it's i'm gonna
sit there in premiere pro i'm gonna
create
like when i created um
american soldier the titles course
that's another one i sold to ae juice
that was a process of i designed the
style frames they were still images they
were laid into a timeline in premiere
pro edited to a music track
from there
it was back and forth between after
effects of premiere pro
and
um you know replacing scenes with you
know single images with animated shots
uh back and forth and
it was a pretty seamless process
the advantage to editing in premiere pro
is of course it's real time compared to
after effects so when you're doing an
edit you can get all your timings just
right then when you have your timings
down even if it's a still image you know
okay this shot this animated shot needs
to be
4 seconds and 12 frames and then i would
literally animate a 4 second and 12
frames shot i'm not going to animate 5 6
7 seconds it's like no you're going to
animate exactly to how long that shot is
in your edit and it's it's it speeds up
the process it's much more seamless
and then you know you render out after
effects back into premiere pro or you
can use the dynamic workflow between the
two
great question mo
jw
really enjoying the stylecraft final
project and design process any plans for
a workshop on completing a larger
project with multiple scenes
um
so there is a bonus at the end of
stylecraft jw
that is from uh stylecraft 1.5
and that's where you're working with
screen graphics and you're you're
actually creating a two scene i think
it's two maybe a three two to three
scene
um piece
that uh
is from start to finish from creative
come up with the creative to
designing it to animating it to
polishing it all those steps so
you'll really get a lot out of the
screen graphics one as well
and then there is a new course coming
out
uh later
this well probably early spring
that is a full sequence i'm not going to
tell you too much more about it but yes
it is a full sequence
great question
and i'm glad you're enjoying the final
project it was a lot of fun to create
that
uh but definitely check and you know
there might be a couple bonuses i add in
stylecraft um soon from the original
starcraft because in the original
starcraft we did do
more of that and i've kind of debated
about bringing some of that into
stylecraft
uh too but we'll see we'll see
uh jason what type of things did you
look for when hiring someone for a
junior position or someone who has been
in the industry has less industry
experience great question
um
first and foremost the demo reel
what um
that the real is everything so when i
had my two um
[Music]
like more specifically my second company
i had uh project blackbird
we hired
um
i don't know i think one time we had
like maybe six associates underneath
those it was me and another guy as a
creative director
and it was all based on the demo reel
right like well let me see your reel
because we get a lot of reels and um
by watching a reel you know my advice to
anyone creating a reel is that it's
60 seconds or less
60 seconds is ideal you can get away
with 30 seconds if it's very very
powerful stuff
um but it's like in a 60-second reel
i can be bored by 15-20 seconds into it
and i'll stop watching it
uh because you can really i mean even on
the first couple shots you can get in a
sense for like okay this guy's got or
this guy or gal's got a lot of talent or
they don't
um and i'm looking for for talent right
now i'm not looking to see like what
what what is this person working on like
who is a big name client that doesn't
matter to me it's just what is visually
what am i looking at
and
how well is it done i also want to know
um
you know i believe that when you create
a demo reel
if you didn't create everything in each
of those shots
you need to call that out
um maybe in the email that you send or a
cover letter and say like hey by the way
this piece i did for such and such
um i did the design for it i did not
animate it or i only did the animation i
did not do the design or i only did you
know the particle systems whatever it
may be tilt this down a little bit here
um
so
the demo reel is everything if you don't
have a reel
you're gonna have a more challenging
time
getting a position for sure
you could possibly get away with
sending like three pieces of your work
that you've done for somebody else or
maybe for yourself
and kind of you know giving more detail
maybe a breakdown of what you did on
these projects or why these projects
you know why you worked on them
but that's pretty much the first thing
is the demo reel
once i've seen the reel if i'm
interested in talking that person more
um i will
and at that point it's all about what is
that who's that person's per what is
their personality like right who is that
person
um
are they easy to talk to
sometimes in this industry they're not
some of us are very introverted and
that's okay
but is that person a nice person or does
this person kind of have an ego which
i've seen that as well
so are they easy to talk to which means
they're going to be easy to work with
you know are they defensive or are they
very straightforward and honest about
things also if i'm going to be working
with a person side by side
it sounds silly but it's like what's
that person's hygiene right
i've worked with animators before that
didn't smell very good
and
it's funny because the post-production
company would
soon find out oops they're with my
lens uh the post-production company
would soon find out and be like oh man
like
we're probably gonna have to not hire
this person again um
i've also funny story worked with
uh designers who um
like to be
um what's the right word since i'm on
youtube here but like
you know have some creative um
enhancements done to them to their brain
um you know throughout the day and um
they like to partake a little bit
and i mean i'm not gonna judge someone
based on that
and um
but if it becomes an issue if someone's
constantly walking out of the office to
go have a smoke break
it can be you know it just it just
depends so
can they still function while they're
doing it i don't know
um but you know there's a lot of
different things but the very first
thing is the real and then it's like you
talk to that person and
are they good to work with do they um
i've also i've worked with a freelancer
before who has flown in for a job just
like me
we were on location
in a major city and
it was pretty apparent by day one or two
that this person
had not done everything that was shown
on their reel and they did not know what
they were doing
and the
studio had spent a fortune on putting
them up in a hotel and flying them in
and all this stuff and feeding them and
so the person was not very honest
and
that was bad they were never hired again
uh hey zach
hello from newfoundland
awesome hello from florida
hey ethan great question what after
effects tools and techniques would you
recommend are the most important for
beginner motion designers what after
effects tools and techniques um well i
would tell you that
the biggest tool you need to have in
your arsenal is a motion science course
um
[Music]
you don't
like our after effects courses or the
ones i've created like these are not
after effects courses that you'll find
like on youtube and and other course
creators these courses go into even more
of the design side of things in after
effects
it's not just technical so it's
important that
you not only learn techniques but you
also learn
some of these like design fundamentals
fundamentals we're not all designers
right and we don't have to be
but
a motion designer who's able to
design as well as animate is in much
higher demand
uh than just someone who can animate
right now there's nothing wrong with if
you're just wanting to be an animator
that's great that's how i started
but what i found was that
as i learned to design as well um i
became much more in demand and my rates
also went up people were more willing to
pay me
more more i never worked for free um so
i wouldn't get focused ethan on
having specific plugins
um
when you're just starting out
now
i do have some plugins i recommend that
all motion designers in my opinion
should have
um but that's more of like when you're
you know a little further down the road
um after effects has so much built into
it
that you could literally
you know be working after effects for
years and years and years without the
need for any third-party
tools or scripts or anything like that
so um just learn after effects to start
learn the program again i'm going to
push motion science after effects
academy
it will get you up and running very fast
in after effects and it'll take you from
beginner level to
you know high level intermediate very
quickly as well if you put in all the
work and you watch all the lessons
you
practice what you learn
that's how you get better faster
and in terms of just inside of after
effects
um again just kind of learn the basics
you know like
animation
is key um
transfer modes are huge in my workflow
you know take a look at transfer modes
play around with the effects and see
kind of what you're drawn to because
there's so many effects built into after
effects
um
just just fine kind of play around and
find out like what
because there's so many different types
of effects you can find certain ones
that are very specific
and you can really be drawn to those and
you can actually develop a style
based on those like for instance fractal
noise right like fractal noise is a
basic effect that for 10 years of me
working after effects i never i never
touched it
and then all of a sudden realized like
oh my gosh there's so much you can do
with fractal noise right
you could base an entire career
in motion design on fractal noise
just because it's
so deep and so powerful for what i can
do
but
yeah also for a very basic tool check
out animation composer
it's not gonna teach you
how to animate
but
like by actually
playing with keyframes it will teach you
um what looks good right different
principles of animation that look good
an animation composer comes with a lot
of free presets and you can buy extra
packs to add on to it
but it's really
it's a tool that i use
to save me a lot of time and animation
and it's one that i've done some videos
on
um if you go back and look at one of my
lives for like three tools i can't
remember what it's called but it's like
three tools that i think every motion
designer should have um it's in there
um check it out it's really really cool
uh minky minky lee what do you think
about starting as a graphic designer
getting experience and then
transitioning into motion design
uh good question
so i see
um
through motion science i see
graphic designers who have been in
graphic design for a number of years
want to transition into motion design
and that's why they're at motion science
which is a great career
move
graphic design is in huge demand i
believe motion design is even more in
demand now because everything is going
to video
and video is king content is king
everyone's creating video and everyone
who's creating video for the most part
wants some type of motion graphic uh in
their video
so
um you know starting as a graphic
designer and learning the fundamentals
of design
is awesome
once you do that transitioning that
graphic design into motion
will probably come a little bit easier
to you
now again at motion science what i teach
is i try to teach a combination of both
i actually focus more on the design side
of things
than the animation side of things
especially in style craft so
i get to ask this a lot so i'll tell you
so like through motion science
i always tell people start with after
effects academy one two and three
because you learn after effects right
but you're learning you're learning
motion principles and you're also
learning design principles as you move
through these three courses
um after that i recommend stylecraft
because that goes even deeper into the
design side of things
and it doesn't focus as heavily on on
animation or motion there is some of it
but you know like my style is more
cinematic
in motion design and cinematic
motion doesn't involve a lot of crazy
camera movements or
animation in general they're more like
you know slow moving camera moves to the
side or
pushing in or pulling back
things like that so
the motion side is not as important
to me in cinematic motion design it's
more about the
the design the overall composition um so
you could go either way minky you could
you could learn graphic design take a
few years to learn that
then move into motion that's a great
great uh plan of attack
or you could try to learn both at the
same time
jason how many hours a day would you
typically spend working on a piece so
jason is that
is that in regards to like a personal
piece which i kind of answered that
earlier or is that in regards to
a client piece i mean if it if it's a
client people always answer both you
know a personal piece like i mentioned
earlier
i'm working
a few hours if you know some of some
pieces come super quick and some of them
it's a struggle and if they're a
struggle
you have to cut your loss at some point
and you move on you say no nope it's not
working
it's going away
maybe it works as a static design
um and that's a potential like oh i can
kind of put this out as a static image
because a lot of times i try to design
and then animate
and
maybe the animation doesn't work but the
design looks great so let's put it as a
design piece
so a few hours on that
if it's really flowing um like i said i
always like to kind of if you take my
courses you'll learn that i like to take
a break
from
the design from looking at a piece your
eyes get tired i've seen the same piece
over and over again so i'll take a break
right i'll i'll work on something and i
get i'll
come back the next day or two days later
or three days later with fresh eyes and
look at it because it's funny you can
work on a piece like this especially
happens when you're working on a piece
all day long like so for a client a
client i'm working on their piece for as
long as they're paying me to work on it
right and i'm trying to budget my time
accordingly so you know if a client has
booked you for seven days on a project
you're working on that project for seven
days if they're paying you to work on a
project for one day you're working on it
for one day
hopefully they know how much time
is required to complete a piece and
you're able to hit that amount of time
yourself
but it's interesting if you work on a
piece like all day long and
you get to the end of the day it's been
a long day and you're looking at the
render or the preview and you're like
man this looks great
this looks awesome
um it's funny because you can come back
the next day
and you open up the quicktime and you
play it
and you're like this looks terrible
or maybe it's not terrible like this
doesn't look as cool as it did yesterday
right
and that happens a lot in motion design
because your eyes are seeing the same
thing over and over and over again
and you're almost like tricking your
mind
thinking like this sounds like really
good
but when you come back with fresh eyes
um
it can look
not so great so
um
yeah take a break have fresh eyes super
important
work as little as possible yet yeah i
mean like there's a balance right
there's there's but i've learned in life
like now as a freelancer
um
you're essentially you're trading time
for money so the more time you work
the more money you're making and it just
depends on what your lifestyle is right
like if you want
um a lifestyle where you're traveling
all the time and you've got a family or
whatever and it costs a lot to do that
then of course you're working more hours
to get paid more to do that if that's
not important and you're maybe a single
person and
or you have a very simple life
then you can work less hours it just
kind of depends on what your lifestyle
is
but yeah
i'm all about working as
little as possible these days
uh brandon do you create style frames
and or storyboards for every project
whether it's personal or commissioned
absolutely not
no
um
commission projects
it depends if they're paying me a fee
to create style frames
or boards for that project now sometimes
a
house will call me up and say we want
you to design the style frames
for this project so a typical example
like digital kitchen would call me up
and say we got a project for
such and such when did you design style
frames we've got three to five days to
do it here's your budget
great i can do it
hang up phone design for three to five
days create style frames
if
they win the project based on the style
frames and it's me and multiple other
designers doing that they're hiring
they're not just hiring me to do style
frames or hiring me and two or three
other people to get different concepts
if they get the job or they're getting
paid to move further along they may call
them up and say okay we got stuff we
need you to board it out now right and
that boarded out means for me it was
creating it was taking those style
frames and actually figuring out you
know every two seconds this is what
you're seeing based on that it's not
sketching some people call uh
storyboarding they assume it's sketching
uh in my line of work it wasn't it was
every two seconds you're seeing exactly
what happens the transitions
everything if they get the job based on
that
then maybe they hire me to animate it
maybe they don't maybe i'm just passing
off my style frames to another team
that's animating it it really just
depends
in other cases
no there's no a lot of projects there
were no style frames
um
or boards it was like
a company calling me up
and saying like here's our budget
here's how much time we have you know
here's a brand guide or here's what the
client wants it really you know it would
vary from job to job um
start on it great we don't have time for
style frames we don't have budget to
spend a few days you know creating style
frames so at that point you have to just
dive in and start creating
um a motion design piece but you have to
be very careful when you're doing that
that you're you're being transparent
with your client
and letting them know like here's where
i'm at here's what it's looking like
because you can get too far down the
road without showing a client something
and they can be like whoa hold up hold
up this is not
what i was wanting and you don't want to
do that like that's bad for the client
that's bad for you it's bad for time
management uh bad for the budget
so
you want to just be very transparent on
what your
what the client is expecting what the
the different uh
uh what's the word i'm losing the word
right now um
the different like check-ins right like
what checking one two three four what
are they what are you expecting there
would be times where we would we would
do check-ins
the client the end client like maybe the
agency hired me we're checking in
checking and checking in they're great
with it and then checking four or five
is when the client sees it and maybe
it's still rough or maybe it's more
finished and the client sees it and says
no
they cut it well at that point you you
revise
your your timeline with your client you
revise the money because there's more
money involved and you basically start
over
so it just it really depends but no
i would say the majority of projects
were no style frames
beforehand on commission projects
personal projects no um
if i feel very pulled to design
something
um i will just design something
and not animate it
like this project i want to do on
thursday this week
i'm just going to build it
as i kind of see it kind of coming out
of my head
i'm not going to design a frame and then
try to animate i'm just going to start
throwing it all into after effects
and seeing what i come up with so i'm
kind of designing volume animating
um
[Music]
the only time
for personal stuff
that i would be designing before
animating is like for a course a lot of
times i'll design maybe what that's
going to look like at the end before
jumping in
and building it
awesome
cool paul
i appreciate that david dave daliza
there's a good one for everyone
starcraft from proflus proflus plus is
no longer available
to the public
um
it is the best content around it is
um proflos plus is an old membership
that i it's still open but it's not open
to the public
um
but there is a new membership coming
thank you brandon
younger picture i love it
um
uh avril can you please make a tutorial
on how to make motion graphics like the
vox media channel i'll have to look that
one up i'm not familiar with what the
vox media channel is but i have thought
about um including within stylecraft i'm
going to actually write that one down so
i can look it up
um let me write that on a quick fox
media channel
uh thank you for the suggestion avril
um i have considered adding more to
stylecraft and there will be more
lessons added to starcraft just so you
know
so once you get starcraft you get access
to this but um
doing like a section on broadcast
graphics and maybe that's what vox media
channel has to do with was broadcast
graphics
because there was an art form to
creating broadcast graphics um with my
last company i owned
we did a lot of network graphics for
like nbc sports and the olympics and amc
and oxygen and
the wwe network lots of different
network graphics i think there's more
than that but um just kind of
understanding what makes good broadcast
graphics and so i think i'm going to
maybe include some of that in stylecraft
in the near future we'll see
daniel cruz
i'm a 2d 3d motion designer that has
done things from explainer logo intros
social media etc but i tend to only land
those jobs how does one land like title
sequence designer jobs on netflix
great question daniel so you need to
create work that showcases that type of
title sequence work that you want to get
that's what creating spec work is all
about um for you daniel so
if i see you're real or i see a webpage
with your work and it has explainers and
logo intros and social media that's why
i'm going to hire you i'm going to hire
you for that
because i see that style i see that type
of work and i know that you're capable
of doing that work if i'm not seeing
anything with title sequence work
i'm not going to hire you for that right
because you have no past experience with
that
and i i can't see any
visual explanation that you know how to
do that kind of stuff
so you want to create a reel with title
sequence work if you want that type of
work
also you don't want to create one reel
that is
explainers logos and social media and
then it's got title sequences in it like
that's that's a no-no because
that confuses me
as a potential hire for you like that
confuses me like why is this guy doing
when you say explainer and social and
logo interest and stuff i think of like
i could be wrong but i think of like
flat vector looking stuff that's
animated
that has that's com that's a 180 from
title sequences for
for the most part i mean there are some
title sequences that are you know flat
vector artwork
but when i think of title sequences i
think of the more cinematic stuff
that's very moody or atmospheric or
whatever i mean there's some awesome
awesome title stuff out there but it's
really different than explainer videos
so um you want to create explainer video
explainer or a title sequence real and
like i said it could be 30 seconds maybe
that 30 second reel is
um they're five second pieces
and maybe there's if they're five
seconds it's 30 seconds long that's
six seconds or so i'm sorry six
different scenes from a title sequence
that you've created right now those six
scenes
you also you could also
two or three of those scenes could be
from the same title sequence that you
built right so it's the same style
the same look but it's different
sections of that made up title sequence
it could be like one shot is the opening
first shot of a title sequence
and then
maybe we jump to shot two which is a
different title sequence and we jump
back to shot three
which is from the first title sequence
but it's a different moment in that
title sequence
so you don't have to create six
different title sequences
their looks their styles whatever
you can create two or three title
sequences and from those two or three
title sequences pick
two or three shots
that is going to be you know in your
reel
um
that's all it needs and that's 30
seconds and then you have like little
five second intro and maybe a five
second outro so now you've got a 40
second reel
that's all you need to do now it that
may feel overwhelming
but this is your opportunity to really
dive in and discover the type of title
sequence that inspires you
and what it is the type of title work
you want to work on right what is daniel
cruz's style you know is it like me
as aka mr black i was very dark and
moody right
what is it and it's it's helping you to
develop your style
with title sequence work it's also
helping you to understand
what makes good title work right because
you're studying different title
sequences and you're trying to build
your own you're trying to get that
creative process going for yourself so
it's just going to make you better
as a title sequence designer
plus you're going to get work eventually
that will pay you to do that work
you get clients that will pay to do that
work
um
okay
i don't know how to pronounce your name
gaga dia ganga diya
um is after effects in premiere pro
enough to get a job yes i mean you just
you could just use premiere pro or you
could just use after effects if you're
just using premiere pro
then it's not going to be a motion
graphics job it's going to be an editing
job
but after effects 100
i mean most all of my paying work came
from just after effects alone
after effects is so deep
um
some people get in their minds that
after effects can just take like
characters and animate them or can just
do simple type
after effects can do
so much it is such a powerful powerful
deep
program
happy new year dale good to have you
here man
uh dale says think pixels dale dale's an
old stylecraft student
i recently was handed a highly
structured mogart for an end card would
love to learn more about how these work
and how to make them and work with them
yeah
so
uh a mogurt
file i've only worked with them a little
bit
um but once you set it up it's not
really made to be um
reverse engineered inside of after
effects it's um
it's made to like be like okay you can
replace this and this and that's it and
they mogarts were made for i think more
for like editors
or
uh
artists after effects artists that um
because i get confused if the mogurt's
the one that goes in premiere pro or if
a mowger it's one that still works in
after effects
because at one point they had two
different types
but anyways they're made for people to
not screw up right so you're you're
limiting parameters that can be changed
like colors type
type faces um position that kind of
stuff because you don't want the
the person who's doing the working with
the file in the end to screw it up so as
a designer you're putting a lot of time
and effort into designing something for
broadcast or whatever and you're like
okay
now you can only mess with these three
parameters and that's it that's all you
need to mess with
so you know they're they're uh
they're interesting i use them every
once in a while i'll download something
off of like envato elements
and for premiere pro use if i need a
quick title
i think a great example is like this
right
this was a mogert file file that i
tweaked the colors and the sizes
and
it works great right it's just very
simple i don't have to
jump into after effects and mess around
with it just it's it's there so
okay
can you break down how you do the wwe
intro
intro um that's maybe at some point i
can
it's pretty basic um
the letters were done in cinema 4d
with a you know a simple spin around
with a camera move
and then
that was brought into after effects
and composited in after effects where we
added like the light flares
color correction
different elements that you see with wwe
that was all finished in after effects
uh do you sell motion if the client
thinks he needs motion but doesn't
actually the project
the project doesn't need it no i mean i
only i don't i never sold myself on on
freelance like people would come to me
and because they knew i could design an
animate so
it wasn't my
place to sell
them on
actual motion if they didn't want it
uh you guys are welcome lots of thanks
for answering questions i'm happy to
answer them i love
answering these questions um
yeah i'm at an hour and i wanted to end
this in an hour
zach has got some great answers there on
the mogart files
uh ethan says what sort of workflow
would you use for kinetic typography
piece
uh it really just depends on the piece
that's a kind of a wide open question
um
if it's type that's like moving and
rotating and the camera is following it
i'm probably going to block it out to an
audio track like if there's a voice over
i'm going to time it all out first or if
it's music and do my time it all out
typically there's voice over with
kinetic type
but it depends connect type again is a
kind of a broad question as well
what is kinetic type right there's a lot
of different ways you could approach
that
hi abraham good day to you too
uh is it possible to get a job as a
self-taught motion designer in three
months yes so uh abraham i don't know if
you're in the beginning of this call i
talked a lot about
being a self-taught motion designer and
how to succeed
as a motion designer but yeah i mean if
you put in the work you know in three
months that's pretty quick but uh you
can do it so like like stylecraft
is my higher level design and motion
course i've seen people get get it done
in 90 days
and i've seen their abilities go
like that and it's not everybody
but the people who put in the time who
put in the effort who do all the work
and really push themselves they can do
it
how much time did it take you to build
skills to start building designs on your
own i mean forever i was just
doing basic design and focus more on the
animation
um until i actually got hired
one day by an agency to design a style
frame and i was really scared to do that
because i didn't think i had the talent
to design and put in a lot of time
you know designing one actually was
three style frames and they were super
happy with it and realized like hey i
can design
um
but
it really it just depends you know time
is irrelevant if it depends like
how much you're focused in
on on on creating
you know design yourself like how much
research are you doing like in
stylecraft again
all of our lessons we're looking at what
makes good motion design why does this
design look great and this one doesn't
you know what are there's there's key
aspects for design that makes certain
pieces look really great and other
pieces don't and you have to understand
what to look for so we talk a lot about
that in stylecraft it's a very involved
process like i said it's it's over the
course of 90 days
and
once you start recognizing like this is
what makes great design this doesn't
it can kind of speed up your workflow
your process of learning design
uh no favorite books from after effects
back in the day it was it was a
trish meyer book that's how i learned
back in like 2099 2000
but anymore i don't really read any
books on after effects
uh to use online services for render
farms for bigger 3d print i mean yes
sometimes it's been a while but yeah
it depends on your deadline if you got a
fast deadline at one point um in my last
company we had a render farm we built me
and this other guy built a render farm
fairly cheaply and it rendered really
quickly
but if you're on a tight deadline and
you've got some intense renders then
yeah render farms can save you
when i do certain animation designs i
have all the ideas how to make it but
once i start i get stuck on certain
things yeah
same problem i used to get stuck too but
i would i would
either do more research on like a
youtube on specific techniques um
for how to overcome something
or i would move on to the next and then
come back to that because maybe that
idea would come to me later i would i
didn't force it i would do as much
research as i could on whatever it is
that was hanging me up
and then i'd come back to it i mean like
in motion design there's always going to
be things that you struggle with things
that are challenging to you and that's
what's good though you want to be
challenged because that's how you get
better
um as a pro right you just you learn
from your mistakes you learn from the
challenges
and you you learn from them you grow
from them
uh is it possibly come emotions aren't
without doing animation yes you can be
just a designer
a motion designer
with emphasis on designer yes i have
friends that are strictly style frame
designer board designers and they do
really well they don't do any animation
so yes you can do i recommend both
personally
because you're more rounded and
you can get more jobs that way but you
can do either one easily
okay i am going to wrap this call up
this was a great q a call
everyone i really appreciate everyone
being on here today
i had a lot of fun answering these
questions and it's fun to always connect
with you guys and kind of find out what
it is that you're
you have questions about right because
sometimes i don't know i can't read your
mind so i appreciate everyone's
questions today and for participating
um if you're watching the replay of this
video
um always feel free to leave a comment
or question below the video
um and i'll do my best to get it
answered for you in the comments um i do
read each and every one of them
so again everyone thank you so much for
being here and uh hope to be back next
tuesday uh for another live session with
you guys
until then
uh keep on creating and uh
doing what you do see ya